[Music]  i'm gonna have to take you apart again  hey dove anything interesting 25  centimeters  dramatically elongated  come on make yourself useful  so uh that was fun right  that's your queue mate  [Music]  you think they can't kill you anytime  they want  hey [ __ ]  [Music]  how do we always get into this  massachusetts behind me we are  witnessing clear signs  of cult activity as the locals engage  [Applause]  hey  thank you layla you're the best  where's the other one where'd it go  [Music]  oh [ __ ] dad's gonna love this one  don't  a new one  kill me and you can't break the blood  yeah i think there's vampire in this  really what does it taste like be  specific  like blood and death and strawberry  sun's coming up let's keep moving let's  keep moving  sure thing edgar allen bro that's a good  one  do you think things will ever go back to  normal  would you want to go back to normal not  if i still have to pay my student loans  [Music]  play it day one with xbox game pass